le caire se prépare aux obsèques
le problème crucial la sécurité renault
billancourt 4000 salariés en chômage
technique trafic d'armes lié à l'extrême
droite
un officier de gendarmerie inculpé les
prix nobel de médecine deux américains
un suédois pour leurs travaux sur le
cerveau madame monsieur bonsoir pour le
dernier hommage de mât à anouar
el-sadate ses amis ses alliés gagne le
caire l'arrivée la plus spectaculaire la
plus symbolique aussi a été ce matin
celle de menahem begin
le premier ministre israélien était
accompagné de ses ministres de la
défense des affaires étrangères et de
l'intérieur et aussi d'un véritable
bataillons d'agents de sécurité
israéliens monsieur begin a aussitôt
rencontré le successeur de sadate hosni
moubarak qui multiplient les
déclarations pour rassurer les alliés
d'égypte et singulièrement israël sur la
continuité de la politique égyptienne
les troubles qui avaient éclaté hier en
haute egypte ont été réprimées il ya eu
au moins 45 morts
la larme a été chaude pour le pouvoir
égyptien du caire pierre serra et à 200
mètres de l'endroit où il a trouvé la
mort
tout ce monument qui reprend la petit
lisant la géométrie plusieurs fois
millénaire des pyramides à côté du
soldat inconnu de la guerre d'octobre
que l'homme d'état le plus illustre de
l'egypte moderne
anouar el sadate serait inhumé demain
ou en attendant les égyptiens comme ils
pouvaient encore croire à la réalité
viennent ici en voitures ralentissent
regardent les impacts de balles qu'on
essaie de colmater à la sous la tribune
et les vitres cassées et se font
expliquer par les militaires présentes
la scène qui mardi dernier a mis fin à
la vie de celui qui fut pour eux le
vainqueur de la guerre est l'inventeur
de la paix il ya quelques jours
seulement
monsieur moubarak travailler dans
l'ombre du rail qui décidez de toupie
décidé par exemple de la rupture ou de
la conclusion des négociations
c'était lui qui décide aujourd'hui
depuis aujourd'hui monsieur moubarak
doit décider tout seul c'est plus grave
c'est plus difficile
il connaît très bien les dossiers mais
bien sûr il n'a pas encore atteint il
faudra probablement un peu de temps le
charisme et le don de sympathie de
saddam en tout cas nul doute que tous
ceux qui viennent ici pour dire demain
un dernier adieu président sadate savent
que le meilleur hommage à lui rendre
c'est finalement deux soupirs aussi vous
bharati dans les pactes des choses il au
monde prend en main donc le destin du
pays semble décidé à poursuivre la
politique du président saleh même si le
régime prend le maximum de précautions
la présence demain matin en un même lieu
d'autant de chefs d'états et de
personnalités officielles pose à l'armée
à la police égyptienne un dangereux
défis notre dossier du jour la sécurité
des puissants de ce monde sa précarité
aussi une précarité qui n'a jamais été
aussi bien illustré que cette année
philippe shatner
comme on peut le voir ici sur ces images
de son arrivée aux défilés de mardi
huit gardes du corps en frêne en
permanence le président sadate des
experts affirmé que sa sécurité
personnelle était la mieux assurée du
monde
les etats-unis ont dépensé 25 millions
de dollars pour équiper des hommes
chargés de protéger sa date
et pourtant toutes ces mesures se sont
révélés insuffisants
d'abord ses gardes du corps n'ont pas
réagi lorsque le commando de tueurs a
ouvert le feu depuis l'un des véhicules
qui participaient au défilé
il semble même que le président sadate
croyant que ces soldats voulait lui
présenter des armes se soit levé pour
les saluer leur offrant du coup une
cible un manque à mai une enquête serrée
devra expliquer par quel complicité les
assassins ont pu se glisser parmi les
troupes du défilé comment ils ont pu se
retrouver dans le même camion placé dans
la file la plus proche de lestrade
présidentielle et comment malgré les
contrôles ils ont pu disposer de
munitions alors que les participants au
défilé ne devait porter que des armes
vie
selon les autorités les quatre assassins
ont été arrêtés on voit ici leur chef
qui a été grièvement blessé le ministre
égyptien de la défense lui-même blessé
lors de l'attentât manqué les tueurs
étaient des fanatiques religieux romaine
je les ai moi-même interrogées qui est
tombée ils m'ont déclaré qu'il savait
qu'il serait tué ou capturé mais que
cela leur rapporte et peu car il irait
au paradis secret contrat tel danger
tous les services de sécurité du monde
sa première femme
rappelez-vous de l'attentât contre lui
comment pouvait-on repéré le trait
mais la donne est et qui se moquaient
d'être aux prises le même la tentative
d'assassinât contre le président reagan
l'oeuvre d'un fou il va chercher la
célébrité il faut se rendre à l'évidence
ce qui est arrivé à jean paul 2 et
agrégats ce qui est arrivé mardi à
anouar el-sadate se reproduira demain
car la sécurité totale n'existe pas le
souhaitons le contraire bien sûr le
président mitterrand arrivera au caire
demain matin autres européens présents
le chancelier allemand helmut schmidt le
président italien le prince charles
d'angleterre le roi baudouin et j'en
passe
ainsi que madame simone veil qui
représentera le parlement européen
valéry giscard d'estaing sera également
présent il y aura très peu de délégation
du monde arabe et on ne sait pas encore
qui représentera l'union soviétique
la délégation la plus importante en
nombre et en prestige et la délégation
américaine même si le président reagan
reste à washington
les explications d'edouard nord c'est
sans doute avec beaucoup d'émotion que
le président américain assistera demain
aux obsèques du président sadate en
direct c'est vrai mais depuis son salon
de la maison blanche et sur un écran de
télévision il sera ici 5 heures du matin
car c'est tous en état major qui s'est
opposé à ce qu'il se rende au caire
et cela uniquement pour des raisons de
sécurité
pourtant là encore vu hier soir le
président reagan aurait fait n'importe
quoi pour se trouver à la place de l'un
de ses trois anciens présidents
américains qui se sont envolés cette
nuit pour le caire une image que
l'amérique n'avait encore jamais vu les
chars nixon gerald ford et jimmy carter
à la maison blanche autour de l'actuel
président mais il aura fallu une
circonstance dramatique et c'est ronald
reagan qu'il a lui-même fait remarquer
pouvoir se réunir ces quatre hommes qui
ont chacun participé à l'histoire du
monde
de ces 15 dernières années un président
américain visiblement très déçu ce soir
mais peut-être déjà un peu rassuré le
successeur du président sadate hosni
moubarak a déjà fait savoir qu'il
acceptait son invitation à se rendre le
plus vite possible à la maison blanche
oui monsieur moubarak s'est entretenu
dès cet après midi avec le chef de la
diplomatie américaine alexandre vig
donnant sa chance à moubarak
tel est en substance le discours que
tient maintenant l'ennemi juré de sa
date le général égyptien ghazli donnons
lui sa chance à condition qu'ils ne
suivent pas les traces de sa date
patrick simpson jose l'a rencontré à
tripoli où il vit en exil politique
solide avec 5000 personnes dont des
leaders politiques derrière des barreaux
elle émerge ici avec l'état d'urgence
après ces violences
il avait fait toutes les lois
répressives imposé par sadate avec
toutes ces choses nous considérons que
la prochaine élection est censée se
dérouler de la même façon que les
précédentes avec sa date et nous
attendons 99% des voix et donc nous
avons demandé aux égyptiens de boycotter
cette élection
malheureusement si moubarak suit les
mêmes pas que ça date
personne ne peut garantir sa sécurité et
il subira le même sort que ceux dont le
général chen zhi a aussi lancé un
avertissement aux délégations étrangères
à l'occasion des obsèques en affirmant
qu'il ne pouvait pas garantir leur
sécurité en raison de la situation
explosive
selon lui règne en egypte pour éviter
tout débordement populaire qui
pourraient faciliter une action des
opposants les autorités égyptiennes ont
donc décidé d'exclure pratiquement le
peuple du caire de l'hommage au raïs
ce qui est surprenant on sait que les
funérailles de sadate ne ressembleront
pas ce que vous avez vécu sur place en
septembre 70 scènes nationales sont
c'est celle de douleur et d'hystérie
collective que le nom verra peut-être
pas demain au caire le cercueil de
nasser porté à bout de bras est touchée
par des millions d'égyptiens venus de
tout le pays
une fouille qui a débordé les services
de sécurité pour rendre un dernier
hommage à celui qui a incarné pendant 18
ans la fierté égyptienne
une foule bouleversé par la mort brutale
de son leader des invités du monde
entier bousculer pratiquement écrasé par
un peuple en délire
demain les funérailles seront
différentes la population ne participera
pas et sera tenu à distance sécurité
oblige
et puis sans doute demain les coeurs des
égyptiens ne battront pas comme ce 28
septembre 70 politique oblige
antenne 2 retransmettra en direct demain
matin les funérailles du président
sadate de 10h à 12h15 le commentaire
sera assurée par léon zitrone
c'est aujourd'hui que le peuple égyptien
doit se soulever il ne doit pas avoir
peur de la loi martiale
cet appel à la révolution c'est l'imam
comme eni qui l'a lancé aujourd'hui de
téhéran en ajoutant je cite l'armée
égyptienne sera déshonoré si elle laisse
israël revenir gouverner ce pays
imam khomeini a ajouté sans humour qu en
iran il n'y avait aucun bouleversement
quand un président était assassiné il
tenait ces propos à l'occasion de
l'investiture d'un autre religieux ali
kameni qui devient le troisième
président de la république après
l'assassinât de son prédécesseur une
victime de plus dans les déchirements du
proche-orient à rome le directeur de
l'information de l'ol paie est mort
aujourd'hui dans sa chambre d'hôtel
victime de l'explosion d'une bombe l'ol
paie par le d'attentats sioniste
c'est une première dans les moeurs
diplomatique le chef de la diplomatie
française claude cheysson en visite
officielle à varsovie a reçu ce matin à
lech walesa le président de solidarité
monsieur besson qui a vu aussi bien sûr
les dirigeants du régime polonais les
autorités religieuses a souligné ainsi
l'attachement de la france à l'évolution
du régime polonais de varsovie georges
bortoli ambiance franche à l'erreur ce
matin alors ma phase de france à
varsovie couple au tce sont recevait
hier au rex à une simple visite privée
nous at-on précisé plus faible pour
ménager la susceptibilité les officiels
polonais susceptibilités qui ne
paraissait pas très effarouchées
d'ailleurs car c'est officiel semble
disposer maintenant un reconnaître une
certaine légitimité et président de
solidarité
c'est si vrai qu'après avoir vu ben
ouais ça tranchées sont étalés tout
naturellement voir monsieur cagna le
numéro un du parti
la france appuie donc la marche vers le
pluralisme politique qui semble se
dessiner ici c'est d'appui français à la
pologne nouvelle claude cheysson nous
l'a confirmé en nous expliquant pourquoi
le premier pays de l'est visité par un
membre du nouveau gouvernement français
était justement la pologne
pourquoi la pologne parce que nous
sentons très forte elle parce que nous
savons qu'elle a besoin d'un appui
extérieur il s'est manifesté sous la
forme matérielle d'envoi de vivre du
serial d'ouverture de crédit parce que
c'est la pologne est depuis des siècles
la france et la pologne sont très liés
c'est un message de sympathie un
témoignage de sympathie que vous donnez
à l'expérience en cours ici l'objet
principal jeudi la presse l'objet unique
de la visite c'est de transmettre ce
message de sympathie c'est pas le mien
et celui du président celui du
gouvernement sur celui des français le
président de la commission européenne
gaston thorn était à paris aujourd'hui
il a été reçu à déjeuner par le premier
ministre pierre moreau le thème central
de leur discussion le plan de relance
européenne que la france va soumettre à
ses partenaires et puis cette précision
très attendu sur la légalité des
nationalisations française par rapport
au traité de rome
on parlait aussi de nationalisation et
j'ai eu dans ce contexte l'occasion de
dire à monsieur le premier ministre
et quelle est l avis autorisé de la
commission après discussion à savoir que
les nationalisations était vraiment
conforme à la législation et au droit
européen que ceci étant dit bien sûr les
entreprises nationalisées donc c'est du
secteur public devrait être soumis aux
mêmes règles que celles du secteur privé
j'ai trouvé un accord complet du côté
français
les autorités françaises comme nous
d'ailleurs pense que ces entreprises
nationalisées doivent être très
indépendante autonome et être soumis aux
règles la concurrentiabilité comme les
autres cette mise au point du président
de la commission de bruxelles intervient
au moment où l'udf annonce son intention
d'engager à propos des nationalisations
une bataille juridique et politique
devant le parlement européen
selon l'udf le projet violerait 14
articles du traité de rome
nationalisation encore avec cette
confirmation apportée hier par le
premier ministre à l'assemblée nationale
les participations industrielles des
banques nationalisées seront comme prévu
remise au secteur privé et cela malgré
la décision de la commission spéciale de
l'assemblée plus maximaliste que le
gouvernement de supprimer cette clause
du projet de loi
le débat sur les nationalisations
commencera mardi prochain le fait du
jour c'est le durcissement du conflit
aux usines renault de
boulogne-billancourt dans ce lieu
symbolique de l'action syndicale la
direction vient en effet de décider de
mettre au chômage technique
les 4000 salariés qui travaillent dans
les ateliers paralysé depuis une dizaine
de jours par les grèves ponctuelles de
l'atelier de montage mécanique cette
décision effective à partir de lundi
pour une durée non précisée a été prise
à l'issue d'une réunion de concertation
entre direction et syndicats qui
voulaient faire l'inventaire de leurs
revendications
alain doublé ce qui les grèves qui
affectent depuis une dizaine de jours
les usines de billancourt ont entraînée
d'abord un ralentissement de la
production de vers cape et depuis lundi
une paralysie totale
c'est ce qu'on appelle une grève bouchon
un responsable syndical
s'explique-t-elle raison de ses
mouvements
et concrètement il ya des problèmes et
un lourd contentieux revendicatif
comme je le disais tout à l'heure du
fait que la politique de giscard mais
également du fait qu'il n'y a pas
d'élection depuis soixante-quinze c'est
à dire qu'il ya le problème de la
réduction du temps de travail les
problèmes de retraite les prix l'emploi
règne de salaires et notamment il des
grande question qui est posée dans les
luttes se déroule à l'heure actuelle
c'est le problème de l'évolution de
carrière des os mais aussi de l'ensemble
des catégories
mais tout c'est actuellement le
gouvernement savait qu elles sont 30
travail salaires tout le gouvernement
effectivement prend des réformes mais
que l'on voudrait voir appliquer
d'autres pistes mais nous pensons que
l'entreprise nationale peut jouer dans
ce domaine un rôle moteur dans le
domaine de la politique économique et
sociale dans notre pays
c'est ce que nous souhaitons en fait la
réponse de la direction était plus
rapide et plus ferme que prévu par les
syndics
à l'heure où nous tournions cette
interview ces responsables cgt ne
connaissait pas encore la décision de la
direction
cette décision c'est la mise au chômage
les ateliers dont l'activité dépend de
l'atelier de montage mécanique
actuellement en grève
cette mesure rappelons le concerne 4000
salariés sur les treize mille six cent
de billancourt le comité confédéral de
la cgt a terminé ses travaux en adoptant
à la quasi unanimité le rapport présenté
par henri krasucki pour préparer le
prochain congrès et cela malgré la
fronde de certains courants la cgt
estime globalement positive l'action du
gouvernement tout en la souhaitant plus
hardis henri krasucki qui sera
officiellement intronisé à la tête de la
cgt lors du congrès a donc la situation
en main son portrait martine gilson si
j'étais on y discute toujours vous avez
une organisation qui représente deux
millions d'adhérents est beaucoup plus 2
millions d'électeurs il suffit de voir
résultats des élections prud'homales
si l'organisation il ya beaucoup de
diversité il peut être qu'on peut
discuter on peut critiquer
et en même temps il faut décider travail
et vient bien entendu mais nous nous
apprêtons à un congrès savez un congrès
qui soient à la mesure des événements
nous vivons une période qui peut
déboucher sur des changements
considérables 57 ans l'oeil malicieux
mais l'humour souvent cinglant henri
krasucki krasus comme on l'appelle va
donc à moins d'une énorme surprise
succédé en juin prochain à georges séguy
son cadet de trois ans une revanche dit
certains en 1967
henri krasucki briguait lui aussi la
succession de benoît frachon la cgt lui
préféra alors georges s'est mis
côté caractère henri krasucki ne
ressemble en rien à son prédécesseur à
la bonne chère à la pêche
il préfère la lecture et l'opéra côté
carrière dans la cgt au sein du parti
communiste
là en revanche de nombreux points
communs henri krasucki vient d'un milieu
modeste et militants un père ouvrier du
textile et communistes une maire
communiste elle aussi il vivra ses
premières années en pologne sa terre
natale avant d'émigrer à paris à la fin
des années trente victimes des pogroms
anti sémite très vite sorti de l'école
krasucki devient ajusteur 1939 à 15 ans
il entre aux jeunesses communistes à
leur clandestine
quatre ans plus tard comme séguy il
connaîtra la terreur des camps nazis
après-guerre l'ajusteur se muent très
vite en permanent syndical cgt il grimpe
dans le syndicat et dans le parti
communiste 37 ans il entre au bureau
confédéral de la cgt
deux ans plus tard on lui ouvre les
portes du bureau politique du pcf 1967
benoît frachon partie il va en tandem
avec ses guy mony le destin de la plus
grosse centrale ouvrière où il sera plus
particulièrement préposé à négociations
une fausse note éclate au congrès de
grenoble en 78 georges séguy veut
l'ouverture aux socialistes notamment
razouqi répond le nouveau style trouvera
son achèvement dans les décisions du
congrès beaucoup disent aussi rond à
l'époque le syndicaliste séguy du
politique krasucki le 10 mai passé ces
lycées face et krasucki tient de plus en
plus le devant de la scène
officiellement en juin il sera le numéro
un
un numéro un réputé plus dur
une confirmation le comité central du
parti communiste il ya de réaffirmer
l'exclusion d'enrichissement et de ses
amis et cela malgré l'appel lancé hier
par 250 membres du pc dont beaucoup
d'élus locaux
le comité central a par ailleurs arrêté
les dates du prochain congrès du pc qui
aura lieu du 3 au 7 février 82 à
saint-ouen une affaire de trafic d'armes
presque banal jusqu'ici met aujourd'hui
en cause un brillant officier de la
gendarmerie membres du fameux gign
le groupe d'intervention de la
gendarmerie nationale les faits
remontent à dimanche dernier on arrête
sur l'autoroute du nord une voiture
transportant 80 pistolet automatique en
provenance de belgique
destinataire une organisation d'extrême
droite à sa tête un ancien gorille de
valéry giscard d'estaing fils d'un
conseiller général l'udf de rouen
aujourd'hui la faire rebondir le
capitaine paul barril numéro deux du
gign ce corps d'élite de la gendarmerie
dont les membres se considèrent comme
les incorruptibles
le capitaine barril vient d'être
inculpée d'infraction à la législation
sur les armes
son portrait françois cornet les
enquêteurs se demandent s'il n'y a pas
une filière de l'autoroute du nord c'est
en effet au péage de senlis qu'ils ont
découvert une cinquantaine d'armes dans
le coffre de la voiture d'un truand
qu'il connaissait déjà les policiers ont
remonté la filière qui les a conduits à
cinq arrestations d'hommes connu dans
les milieux d'extrême droite
mais aussi effectivement vers le numéro
deux du groupe d'intervention de la
gendarmerie
inculpé par le juge d'instruction de
seine saint denis alors ce soir on se
demande quels étaient les liens réels du
capitaine barril avec des individus
aussi divers qu'un ancien mercenaire ou
un tenancier de café du raincy étrange
personnalité donc que paul barril chef
adjoint deux hommes du groupe
d'intervention de la gendarmerie
nationale que nous voyons ici
il est mis en cause par un ancien
camarade de régiment inculpés dans cette
affaire
il est soupçonné d'avoir fourni
même le capitaine barril est âgé de 34
ans nous l'avions rencontré il ya
quelques mois
au cours de cet entraînement à maisons
alfort pour prendre l'exemple
d'aujourd'hui nous avons commencé ce
matin pour faire 10 km de footing en
bois de vincennes ensuite de 9 heures à
midi nous avons fait du karaté de self
défense et après midi est consacré aux
tirs aux revolvers au tir au fusil à la
musculation et au cas concrets en saxe
dans la peau région du pool bar il a
participé à la plupart des opérations du
groupe d'intervention de la gendarmerie
depuis sa création en 1972 il a commandé
notamment la reprise de la grande
mosquée à la mecque en 1981 occupée par
les musulmans intégristes entendu
aujourd'hui par le juge d'instruction de
bobigny il a été laissé en liberté mais
ses supérieurs ont décidé de le placer
aux arrêts de rigueur quant aux cinq
autres inculpés de ce trafic
ils sont tous été écroués paul barril a
déclaré au magistrat instructeur qu'il
avait simplement voulu rendre service à
son ami en lui fournissant les
détonateurs
ce dernier selon le capitaine voulait se
servir d'explosifs pour creuser une
fosse de tirs dans un ball-trap le
capitaine barril affirmant qu'il était
absolument pas au courant de ce trafic
d'armes entre la belgique et la france
l'homme du jour
ils sont trois ce sont les tranches
herrscher qui ont reçu aujourd'hui le
prix nobel de médecine le premier à être
décerné par l'académie de stockholm
ces trois hommes ce sont deux américains
que vous voyez ici roger sperry et des
vip plus beau qui lui partage son prix
avec un suédois dorsenne visent elles
trois têtes donc pour un cerveau martin
à la réunion puisque ce sont leurs
travaux sur le cerveau qui les ont fait
couronner aujourd'hui un cerveau de
cette taille là le cerveau humain un
organe très complexe de 10 à 13
milliards de cellules nerveuses qui sont
connexion les unes avec les autres qui
sont le siège du sommeil de la mémoire
de la colère de la parole des
mathématiques une redoutable boîtes
noires dont on sait que très peu de
choses et les deux ou trois choses que
l'on sait du cerveau humain
on lui doit entre autres à ces trois
récompenses et d'aujourd'hui alors
hubbell et vise l on va passer très
rapidement on fait des recherches
extraordinaire sur le circuit nerveux
qui va de l'appareil photographique
l'oeil jusqu'au cerveau et que fait le
cerveau quand l'oeil voix et l'ours
péricat reald alors ce père il a
découvert qu'en fait nous n'avions pas
un cerveau qui met deux cerveaux deux
hémisphères cérébraux que vous voyez ici
reliées entre normalement par des ponts
un pont qui s'appelle le corps calleux
qu'il a particulièrement étudié et il a
montré que le cerveau gauche et le
cerveau droit n'étaient pas les mêmes il
y avait le bavard le rationnel celui qui
était responsable du langage de
l'écriture du calcul et l'émotionnel le
mu est responsable de tout ce qui n'est
pas verbal et il a montré l'importance
de ces ponts entre les deux hémisphères
qui permettent aux deux cerveaux
différents qui ne remplissent pas les
mêmes fonctions de s'informer
respectivement de leur expérience
il a étudié ceci sur les animaux et il a
étudié ceci chez des hommes qui ont été
lésés lors de certaines opérations je
vous ai présenté ici le cerveau gauche
le cerveau droit le pont entre les deux
et monsieur sperry a surtout couper la
communication entre ces deux lobes chez
des animaux ou étudier chez des malades
qu'ils avaient spontanément coupé au
cours d'interventions chirurgicales pour
comprendre ce qui était à gauche ce qui
était à droite
sachant que à chaque fois notre cerveau
gauche commande notre main droite
notre cerveau droit notre main gauche
pourvu que ça marche
c est en tout cas très important ça
permet de comprendre le cerveau
proprement dit et puis aussi certains
troubles et surtout d'améliorer beaucoup
la condition de ceux qui ont une lésion
cérébrale
donc il y à des applications
fonctionnent toujours des applications
pour ce genre de choses merci martin je
vous propose de retourner maintenant à
boulogne-billancourt
martine gilson et sur place avec les
réactions ce soir après la nouvelle de
la mise en chômage technique de 4000
salariés
martin oui christine j'ai près du mois
jean louis fournier secrétaire du
syndicat cgt de renault billancourt
jean louis fournier que pensez vous de
la décision de la direction bien je
crois que c'est la mauvaise solution que
la prise à direction il y avait d'autres
solutions possibles qui ont été
proposées par l'ensemble des
organisations syndicales au niveau du
groupe renault cet après-midi à la
direction notamment de régler les
conflits en cours par la voie de la
négociation et de langage et les
discussions au niveau de l'ensemble du
groupe renault c'est ce qu'ont proposé
les syndicats mais malgré cela la
direction est passé outre et nous
pensons que cette solution n'est pas
réaliste
c'est pour cela que nous avons envoyé
une lettre dans l'après midi à la
direction ils lui faisant savoir que
nous étions pour notre part disponible
jour et nuit y compris le week-end pour
régler les problèmes qui se posent dans
l'entreprise qu'est ce que vous allez
faire maintenant eh bien nous allons
entreprendre des démarches
ce week-end nous allons réunir nos
militants et prendre les dispositions
qui s'imposent pour que la direction
revienne sur sa décision et nous pensons
que les choses peuvent s'arranger si la
direction fait preuve de réalisme et de
sérieux
ce sont donc les réactions à chaud à
boulogne billancourt dans les gigis ne
nous parlons aux cultures maintenant
avec une bonne nouvelle pour tous les
amateurs de musées l'accès aux musées
nationaux sera gratuit le mercredi à
partir du 1er janvier prochain jacques
landes le ministre de la culture l'a
annoncé aujourd'hui françois mitterrand
a inauguré une merveilleuse exposition
aujourd'hui l'exposition au grand palais
sur les fastes du gothique
cette exposition réunit les chefs
d'oeuvre du 14e siècle français
l'impression que pour le fonctionnement
pour 2016 culture toujours culture d'un
autre monde le japon le théâtre kabuki
l'équivalent pour les japonais de
l'opéra comique se produit en ce moment
à paris évidemment pour nous cela ne
ressemble pas beaucoup à ce que nous
apprécions à l'opéra comique mais c'est
une belle démonstration d'une tradition
très vivante au japon l'exemple pour les
français d'un théâtre musical réussi
yauba grégoire qui l'a vu à tokyo nous
le montre
c'est ici que chaque jour 2500 personnes
franchissent le seuil de kabuki vers 11
heures du matin pour y passer six heures
d'affilée où ils verront jusqu'à huit
pièces c'est dire l'engouement des
japonais pour ce théâtre l'origine du
kabuki remonte au xviie siècle où il
s'est inspiré en grande partie du
théâtre nô et de celui des marionnettes
c'est un art populaire qui entremêle le
théâtre la danse et la musique un
spectacle de kabuki n'est pas une pièce
au sens occidental du terme c'est à dire
une pièce que l'on met en scène fallait
pas un texte que l'on met en scène c'est
un ensemble d'éléments il ya des
éléments musicaux il ya des éléments
chorégraphiques il ya des éléments
littéraire mais tout ceci est donné tout
ceci ne fait pas l'objet d'une mise en
scène en ce sens sur le plan théorique
c'est assez intéressant puisque ça
corresponde à ces prêts à l'idée que
brecht ne pouvait s'offrir du modèle par
exemple lorsque lorsque brest créer un
spectacle créé tout le spectacle n'est
pas acteur du kabuki qui veut c'est un
art qui se transmet de père en fils ou
un longue apprentissage est nécessaire
pour interpréter les différents
personnages l'art vocal celui du
maquillage et du geste la danse et
l'expression des yeux c'est le cas de
henrique 3
le plus célèbre des acteurs du japon
sixième du nom c'est son grand-père qui
crée un la dynastie il ya 150 ans lui
commença sa carrière à 8 ans
à
le maquillage très long à réaliser fait
partie du rite les bons ont seulement le
coin externe de l'oeil prolongé par un
trait rouge tandis que les mauvais ont
le visage peint en bleu le public
reconnaît d'emblée un personnage à son
costume qui peut peser jusqu'à 28 kg
théâtre énigmatique pour les occidentaux
mais riche en enseignements d'ailleurs
le public ne s'y trompe pas puisque le
kabuki à travers toute l'europe et à
paris en ce moment fait salle comble car
c'est un spectacle complet
un mot de tennis avec une victoire de
yannick noah en quarts de finale de
l'open de barcelone
il a battu le tchécoslovaque thomas
schmidt la partie sera plus rude en demi
finales puisque non affrontera ivan
lendl et maintenant alain gillot-pétré
quel temps nous annoncez vous pour le
week-end à pour ne pas changer médiocre
bien sûr tant samedi que dimanche
en attendant ce week-end le médoc les
extrêmes de température relevée par la
météo nationale à 13h aujourd'hui le
minimum 7 et à lille il faisait 13
degrés maximum à nice et autonomie ni
dire année 22 degrés la prévision pour
demain sur notre carte beaucoup de
nuages encore pas mal de pluies
localement orageuses sur l'extrême est
du pays et ailleurs donc principalement
sur le centre le nord et l'ouest encore
des averses des passages nuageux
quelques éclaircies et des vents assez
forts d'ouest près des côtes de la
manche
enfin il est possible il est possible
qu'une nouvelle perturbation aborde
l'ouest du pays dans l'après midi
la prévision de température maintenant
pour demain région par région du nord au
sud dix à onze le matin en moyenne
l'après-midi 16 à 17 en moyenne sont
température un petit peu plus faible un
peu plus faible qu'aujourd'hui mais tout
de même encore assez douces
enfin notre agenda pour demain samedi 10
octobre le soleil se lèvera à 7h04 et se
couchera 18h10 à paris c'est la fête des
six là j'attendais le 24 juillet pour
vous souhaiter la vôtre christine une
dernière nouvelle la cérémonie des
funérailles du président sadate sera
légèrement retardé demain matin pour des
raisons de sécurité elle commencera à
10h 20 rendez vous donc à 10h20 demain
matin sur antenne 2 pour suivre en
direct cette cérémonie dont le
commentaire sera assurée par léon
zitrone gérard ce bague et pierre ses
reins vous avez rendez vous tout à
l'heure à 23h pour le dernier journal
avec avec l'aude
merci d'avoir suivi cette édition à
demain 20 heures
à